all right garm what was your most
expensive figure that you purchased okay
so
what was the most expensive figure that
you guys i don't know you know what you
bring yourself and then if it happens to
be more than the one that we found then
you get the point
okay well you know what
i'm going to go out and say
no no no no no no no i know i didn't get
the most expensive figure
so what was the most expensive figure
do you think are you saying that uh the
amelia one was the most expensive one
that you found i thought it was that was
seven hundred dollars that was seven
hundred dollars yeah is it not i found a
more expensive one
i actually took a photo of it just for
proof
what the [ __ ] gone
all right that's
gone that's not a figure where are we
gonna display that
you have to go through here
so obviously i had the most expensive
figure store and to tell the story of
this one as well so my first instinct
was of course to go to the hentai
section because you know sydney aside
sometimes the most expensive figures are
the hentai ones they are they are pricey
as we've said
yeah yeah as we've just established and
i saw some for like 150 dollars at first
i was like oh that's pretty expensive
200 oh okay now now we'll get into the
territory 250 all right 300 okay and
then i went into the fate section
where dreams died because because of
course i did where dreams are made where
dreams are made by the world
and holy [ __ ] i found so many good
figures and like some of them and like
as you're about to see with this one
i've bought
like at which point do we not call it a
figure and does it become a statue you
know
bring it on out i mean i see it in the
corner of my eye but uh it's pretty fun
[Laughter]
so oh my god
what the [ __ ] god where are we gonna put
that so i'm gonna kind of like
can you even see me anymore on camera
so i found a few fake figures i don't
know if you can even see me right i
can't hear you over the [ __ ]
the monolith slab in front of you so i
found this for
500 and something bucks 150 dollars 550
dollars and i was just like there's no
way
i'm gonna either take it off the table
or open all right all right can uh can
can one of you guys open it
someone's gonna i'm gonna need help
cracking that boy open
it's literally like a fancy action board
that's so cool though oh that is pretty
cool it's actually like made of like
felt yeah
okay so i found that and i'm just like
yes i have found the most expensive
figure in the store and it's a figure i
want because
that was not a figure because that looks
[ __ ] amazing that's a statue
that looks [ __ ] amazing and i'm like
i want this and then i turn the corner
and i see this amelia figure for 700
and i'm just like
[ __ ] my life
i can't buy a 550 figure and a 730
figure at once so i was like the reason
i almost ran out of time was because i
was just sitting there with both figures
next to each other being like
do i go for the win do i go for the
point or do i go for my heart
and always the point
and i looked at the emilia figure and
i'm just like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna make the
same mistake as subaru i'm gonna go [ __ ]
emilia i'm gonna go for the thing that's
right in front of me and i chose the
fate figure and you know what
i don't regret a damn thing that is
actually the coolest thing i've ever
seen though but you also wouldn't have
got the point anyway if you went for the
image yeah because i found one you see i
think you should have looked a little
harder in the hentai section okay
because i found this one and it's uh 935
oh what is that what is it what can i
have a look at that
it's uh
from uh
which is actually a game i've played
and uh it's it's just like a witch girl
that doesn't from this very 900 yeah but
it's from a very famous uh hentai game
and it's yeah 935 dollars there's the
photo
so yeah uh instead i um you went for
your heart i went for my heart and i'm
just i'm just like i respect that and
i'm just like um so guys so guys um like
if it's like a little too big for the
studio like uh what what are we doing
for the figures
what are we doing if it's like too big
for the studio i think there's like a
place like behind the toilet like like
like yeah we have plenty of room in the
toilet yeah there's plenty of room in
the toilet
what if it's too big for the studio like
you know
then it's just then it's just like
useless i don't know if you see how big
the studio is it's it's pretty big
we can get a little pedestal
you guys are you guys aren't fake fans
you guys aren't fake
i think it looks cool
is that
while they're still assembling this
absolute
okay absolute unit